hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
wir haben heute lust auf etwas leichtes
deswegen gibt's bei uns raps und zwar
mit lachs und spinat und auch ein
bisschen tomate und es wird wirklich
super lecker die raps habe ich jetzt
schon vorbereitet also die können
wirklich auch selber backen
dazu habe ich jetzt bereits auch schon
ein video gemacht hat wir darauf
zurückgreifen oder falls es zu wenig
zeit habt oder wirklich gar keine lust
habt sich selber zu machen können wir
sie natürlich auch fertig kaufen
aber ich empfehle ich immer die
selbstgemachte variante ich zeige euch
jetzt mal die zutaten für die lachs raps
und zwar brauche ich dafür ein esslöffel
olivenöl 4 tomaten eine charlotte eine
city etwas zitronensaft einen esslöffel
butter und eine knoblauchzehe 200 gramm
spinat 200,0 oder crème fraiche und ich
habe es hier noch viel lachsfilets ohne
haut und zwar sind es etwa 500 gramm
unter noch salz und pfeffer ich mache
jetzt einfach mal die tomaten und zwar
gibt es einen esslöffel olivenöl in
einer pfanne oder einen großen topf
jetzt nehme ich erst mal tomaten und die
schalotten die schotten werden jetzt
fein gewürfelt
die chili wird ist auch fein gewürfelt
jetzt kommen die zwiebeln und die
chemieindustrie arbeiten sie jetzt bei
mittel hitze glasig gedünstet und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich auch schon mal die
tomaten dürfen
jetzt kommen die tomaten mit hier rein
jetzt auch ein bisschen zitronenschale
da müsst ihr natürlich darauf achten
dass es ein bio zitrone und waren
zurückgekommen
die airline nicht übertönen
michaela schreiber
sie kämpft grafiker mit ihrem lösen
ein spritzer zitronensaft mit rein und
dann schmeckt das ganze mit salz und
pfeffer
lasst die tomaten einfach so ein
bisschen zergehen
nach 34 minuten könnt ihr die tomaten
jetzt raus nehmen dann nehme ich die
gleiche pfanne oder den gleichen topf
für den spinner
jetzt kommt die butter in den heißen
topf und die krise werde ich jetzt
feiern
da kommen jetzt die knobloch dreh mit
rein
kurz minuten rühren es ist nicht ganz
viele ganz tolle aromen dies ist ein in
einem rap verbinden
jetzt kommt das spiel noch mit rein und
es sieht jetzt mal ganz viel aus mit
gleich ganz wenig dass er jetzt gleich
zusammen
am besten kommt abdecken und jetzt kann
ich ja zwischenzeit schon mal die pfanne
erhitzen
da habe ich jetzt eine geschichte getan
und muss dann das lachsfilet mit fett
ausbacken
jetzt ganzes lachsfilet in die pfanne
und weg von jeder seite etwa vier bis
fünf minuten anbraten
den spinat habe ich jetzt bereits mit
salz und pfeffer gewürzt jetzt wird sich
auch noch den schmand fritz salz und
pfeffer und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr
da zum beispiel nach dem einfügen oder
auch andere kreative im garten haben
immer ungewiss
jetzt den lachs mit weißem pfeffer
würzen
jetzt nehme ich die lachsfilets ihr
könnt ihr jetzt gerne auch in würfel
schneiden oder zum ganzen lassen wenn
ihr ganz grosse torchance hat
ich habe zur mittelgroße mit 20 cm
durchmesser und wetzt einmal längs
halbieren
nämlich einen weizen partie da kommt
jetzt etwas von das dauert will braucht
man nur in die mitte dann der dax
die halten spinat
dann dax
und ein bisschen tomaten
und jetzt könnt ihr ihn auf der einen
seite gerne auch offen lassen so mache
ich das jetzt klappt jetzt hier unten zu
und rollen dann ein
und so fühle ich jetzt noch ein paar und
die kann man übrigens warm und kalt ganz
gut essen also man kann sie jetzt auch
vorbereiten und damit die kant als mekka
helfen
so serviere ich jetzt die dax spitze
wie gesagt könnte sie kalt oder warm
essen und ich finde sie gehen wirklich
super schnell als ich stand jetzt nicht
länger als 14 25 minuten in der küche
und ja ich finde sie sehr gut vor allem
zu als snack zwischendurch oder auch
gerne auch mal als hauptmahlzeit also
falls ist jetzt nach machen wollt geht
auf der etat stets noch mal ganz genau
für euch und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß und nachmachen und falls ihr gerne
noch weitere raps in wolfen schreibt mir
in die kommentare
dann mache ich natürlich auch gerne
andere für euch also bis zum nächsten
mal
jetzt schilder weg
ja komm praktischen vorschlag meiner
nichte